[Music]
chelsea is with us chelsea is in
jacksonville florida hi chelsea how are
you
uh hi i'm doing good how are you better
than i deserve what's up
um i just had a quick question first off
thank you for your show and your
principles and everything i cry every
time i watch a debt-free scream i can't
help it me too i've been doing it 30
years
um i had a quick question so my husband
and i are on baby step three all of our
debt is paid off we paid off
uh the harley in december and that was
the last of our car payments and any of
our debts
we currently have our second baby on the
way
due in february
and
my husband recently proposed the idea of
selling the bike
and i don't know how i feel about it
because i bought it for him
um
as a wedding gift um
and
i've been trying to get him to sell the
truck for years but i never thought he
would go
for selling the motorcycle um
so i guess i'm just wondering what you
think
hmm
do you want to sell it for money
yeah just just sell it for cash i think
he's
maybe thinking more about
uh
you know
family and two kids and potential for
something bad to happen um so that's
what i was wondering is he trying to
sell it because you all need the cash or
is he trying to sell it because and i've
heard of this i've had buddies that said
man i suddenly riding my motorcycle felt
selfish i got two little kids and i'm
i'm putting myself in a high risk
category right and so i'm to sell it
because of that
but it sounds like that's why
i think that's where his heart is i
think he's just thinking about it a
little more he loves writing it and i
you know i feel bad him thinking about
it but now that he's mentioned it now my
thoughts are churning and thinking about
well we could get our emergency fund
i'll say all stocked up if he sold it
and so what's the call what's the bike
worth
um it's a 09 soft tail i i looked online
maybe about 10 000. okay and what's the
uh two cars that you're driving worth
um
right now um he's got a truck an 06 gmc
oh gosh i have no idea what they're
worth they're just
what's your household income
um household income is about 120. okay
so you can afford the bike you're out of
debt
you have an emergency fund you have a
ten thousand dollar toy in the garage
so this has absolutely nothing to do
with money
right has nothing to do with money
so then it comes down to why does he
want to sell it and are you okay with
that reason
if his reasoning is what john is saying
that he's going i got two kids this
feels i could lay this thing down leave
her with two kids i don't want to do
that it takes some of the joy out of the
bike
for now i'll i'll pick up a bike later
i'm an empty nester we'll buy two of
them and tour the world in them you know
and send the kids off to college and
whatever but if that's his reasoning um
if i'm in your shoes i feel pretty loved
yeah i do
he's a good man yeah
i mean
you don't have a financial reason to
sell the bike
if it was a boat and it was ten thousand
dollars and it was in the garage
and you guys wanted to keep it and it's
a toy and you're out of debt and you
make 120 a year your total of all your
vehicles is less than half your annual
income which it definitely is
then you know you don't have too much
going on here with stuff that has wheels
and motors and you don't have a problem
um and so
you know it and ten thousand dollars
doesn't change your life in the positive
or the negative in your situation
because you've done such a good job on
all the other fronts
so i think it just comes down to what's
his motivation and are you okay with
that because i think his motivation is
forward-looking and your
sadness is
due to the nostalgia of you gave it to
him from the past and as a wedding gift
she was surprised that
he would ever sell
a gift that i gave him one time you know
what i mean yeah i get that a little bit
of that but yeah but it's a if if it's
you know we don't have him on the line
so we don't know what's driving this but
no pun intended but um
but yeah you just have to decide there
what's what's going to happen and so the
calls we usually take are the opposite
yeah is he won't sell it he's got three
kids and we need the money and he's
being reckless and it's a sixty five
thousand dollar bike you know and so
yeah that kind of stuff so i i'm with
you
my first thought is man if he's selling
it because he's starting to look forward
and thinking i i need to go take up golf
this guy's a stud i was gonna say yeah
what a good guy